Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Pour l’anniversaire de mes cinq ans,
j’ai visité le département
des antiquités égyptiennes au Louvre.
Et c’est là, au milieu des momies
et du matériel des scribes,
que j’ai su ce que je voulais faire
de ma vie.
J’ai alors annoncé à tout le monde
que quand je serai grande,
je serai archéologue-écrivain.
Évidemment,
ce métier hybride a fait sourire
tous les adultes présents ce jour-là.
Mais en regardant autour de moi,
j’ai croisé le regard
d’un homme à tête de chacal,
puis d’un hippopotame à tête de femme.
Je me suis dit que certaines grandes
personnes avaient osé faire des mélanges
vraiment très audacieux.
Et finalement, mon futur métier
d’archéologue-écrivain
ne m’a pas paru si fou que ça.
J’ai donc persisté dans mon choix
jusqu’à aujourd’hui et ça marche
puisque le dernier livre que j’ai rédigé
a été traduit en dix langues.
La raison pour laquelle ce métier
composite fonctionne si bien,
c’est parce que l’archéologie
et la littérature poursuivent le même but.
Il s’agit de gratter
la terre ou les souvenirs
pour découvrir la nature
profonde de l’être humain.
Écrire un roman ou partir à la découverte
des comportements rituels
des humains du passé,
en fin de compte, c’est la même chose.
C’est se lancer
dans une chasse aux fantômes.
C’est enquêter sur les habitudes
de personnes qui n’existent pas
ou qui n’existent plus pour esquisser
le profil d’une humanité multiple.
Mon métier, c’est donc
de faire entendre la voix
de personnes vivant dans d’autres
dimensions que les nôtres,
des gens qui évoluent
dans le passé ou dans la fiction.
Certains d’entre vous
se diront peut-être :
« Oui, d’accord, mais pourquoi
est-ce que je devrais écouter
ce que ces personnes nébuleuses ont
à me dire depuis leurs mondes lointains ?
Vous êtes bien gentils
mais j’ai des choses à régler,
ici et maintenant. »
Oh, je vous crois.
C’est le mal de notre époque.
Nous sommes tous débordés
et pourtant il faut prendre le temps
d’écouter les voix
provenant des mondes parallèles,
tout simplement car elles ont
de précieux conseils à nous donner
pour mieux vivre notre humanité
dans notre dimension,
ici et maintenant.
Ce sont des fantômes bienveillants.
Ils sont comme ces vieux et ces vieilles
qui ont toujours une histoire
passionnante à nous raconter,
pour nous faire passer
le très mauvais café soluble
qu’ils nous servent en même temps.
Mais si on les écoute bien,
ils nous montrent les tragédies
que nous pourrions connaître
si nous commettons
les mêmes erreurs qu’eux.
Ce faisant, ils nous donnent
des pistes concrètes
pour améliorer notre rapport aux autres,
à la nature et à la civilisation.
Sauf que pour écouter leurs conseils,
il faut comprendre leur langue.
Et c’est là que commence
le travail de l’archéologue.
Nous, les archéologues,
nous écoutons les échos
de ces voix déformées par le temps
pour retranscrire leurs paroles dans
un langage intelligible par le public.
À ce stade de notre rencontre,
j’imagine que certains d’entre
vous ont envie de me dire :
« Oui, tout ça est très poétique.
C’est surtout très théorique.
Comment faites-vous concrètement
pour réaliser
cette traduction du passé ? »
Je vous préviens tout de suite,
on va sortir de la poésie quelque temps
parce que c’est un autre point commun
entre les archéologues et les écrivains,
nos méthodes de travail
sont peu ragoûtantes.
Les écrivains fouillent
les bas-fonds de l’esprit humain
tandis que les archéologues
fouillent leur équivalent matériel,
c’est-à-dire les poubelles, les ruines
et les tombes de nos ancêtres.
Et justement,
dans le domaine de l’archéologie,
je suis spécialiste du monde des morts.
Je côtoie des squelettes toute la journée
et je fais parler ceux qui n’ont plus
que leurs os pour s’exprimer.
Et ma période de prédilection,
c'est la préhistoire.
Cette très longue période de temps
où nos ancêtres se façonnent eux-mêmes
pour devenir des humains
entre 3 millions d’années
et 12 000 ans avant le présent.
Une période qui a vu naître
des inventions capitales
comme le feu, la musique, la peinture,
mais pas encore le plus beau
de tous les arts, à savoir l’écriture.
Les archéologues comme moi
ne disposent pas de sources écrites
pour les aider à comprendre les vestiges
archéologiques qu’ils découvrent
et c’est une difficulté
supplémentaire de taille.
J’ai décidé d’être l’interprète
des sociétés les plus muettes
de notre histoire.
Alors, on pourrait s’interroger
sur la raison psychanalytique de ce choix,
sur ce que ça révèle
de ma personnalité profonde.
On ne se connaît pas depuis longtemps
mais la question est superflue.
On a tous compris que je suis
juste une très grosse bavarde.
J'ai une langue à faire parler les morts.
Pour réaliser ce petit
miracle d’outre-tombe,
je vous avoue que je procède par étapes.
La première, c’est bien sûr
d’extraire les vestiges du sol.
Une pioche, une truelle, un pinceau
et voilà qu’apparaît une fosse dans
laquelle se trouve un outil en pierre
et un squelette humain.
La seconde étape de notre travail
peut alors commencer.
Il s'agit d'interpréter
les vestiges exhumés.
Le but,
c’est de restituer les gestes qui
ont été effectués par nos ancêtres
afin de permettre la création
de ces objets, leur utilisation
et enfin, leur abandon dans cet état.
L’état dans lequel l’archéologue
vient tout juste de les trouver.
Parce que, une fouille archéologique,
c’est un peu comme une image
sur un polaroïd.
C’est le souvenir d’un instant précis,
figé dans le temps,
et il nous faut découvrir
tout ce qui s’est passé avant.
Pour ça, nous disposons
d’une armée de spécialistes
qui vont se relayer au chevet des vestiges
et les analyser grâce
à des méthodes de pointe.
Par exemple, les traces de taille
sur la surface de l’outil en pierre
suggèrent qu’il a été façonné
par un tailleur très expérimenté.
En décortiquant la composition
chimique de la roche,
on s’aperçoit qu’elle a été extraite
à des centaines de kilomètres de là.
Et en regardant un peu mieux le squelette,
la forme de son bassin,
le degré de maturité de ses os,
nous comprenons qu’il s’agissait
autrefois d’une jeune femme,
morte dans l'adolescence.
Alors, face à cette page blanche qui
attend d'être noircie d'explications,
l’archéologue écrit l’histoire
petit à petit.
Tous ces objets sont
autant de bribes de mots
qui, sous la plume du scientifique,
se transforment en phrases
pour vous raconter
une funeste trajectoire individuelle.
Ici, pour résumer,
nous avons une roche rare
qui a été taillée par un artisan virtuose.
Un objet précieux qui a été déposé
près du cadavre d’une jeune femme
qui a autrefois été une fille,
une mère, une sœur, une amie.
Bref, tous ces objets nous chuchotent
que nous sommes face
aux vestiges de tendres funérailles.
On est alors saisi d'empathie.
Le deuil de l’autre devient
aussi un peu le nôtre
et on rédige sans problème
son rapport de fouille
et l’article scientifique
qui résume notre découverte.
Sauf que parfois on se retrouve
avec des grains de sable
sous les touches du clavier.
C’est le cas lorsque l’on fait face
à des vestiges archéologiques obscurs
qu’on ne sait absolument pas
comment interpréter.
Si un squelette dans une fosse,
c’est bien souvent le résultat
du dernier hommage rendu à un être cher,
ça peut aussi être le témoignage
d’un sacrifice humain
ou d’un meurtre dont on a cherché
à dissimuler la victime.
Sur l’étagère de la grande
librairie de l’humanité,
il y aussi bien des ouvrages
de Joan Didion
que des romans de Stephen King
ou de Georges Simenon.
Ici, par exemple, nous sortons très
probablement de la littérature blanche
pour nous diriger vers un genre
beaucoup plus sombre.
Pour ceux qui ne comprendraient pas
ce qu’ils ont sous les yeux,
laissez-moi vous guider.
Nous avons la moitié supérieure
d’un cadavre humain
qui a été couché sur le ventre
dans cette position
et son corps a été soigneusement
découpé au niveau de la taille.
Et le bas de son corps a été retiré
pour être remplacé
par le bas d’un corps de chèvre.
J’ai dû expliquer ceci
lors de ma thèse de doctorat.
Je ne vous cache pas que j’ai été prise
d’un léger mouvement de panique
car ça ne ressemblait absolument à rien
de ce que j’avais pu voir auparavant.
Et que faire face
à une situation aussi inédite ?
Personnellement, j’ai choisi d’avoir
recours à l’ethnoarchéologie.
Pour le dire sans jargonner,
j’ai fait le tour du monde
pour voir comment les populations
actuelles dites traditionnelles traitent
le corps de leurs ennemis
et les cadavres de leurs ancêtres.
Rien d’identique à ceci
ne s’est présenté à moi.
J’ai alors commis une erreur
fatale dans mon désarroi.
J’ai tenté de tout intellectualiser,
de tout millimétrer,
pour ne surtout pas risquer d’interpréter
ces vestiges n’importe comment.
J’ai donc décortiqué les pratiques
mortuaires de centaines de populations.
Je les ai disséquées pour les transformer
en groupes de gestes,
chaque groupe de gestes
correspondant à une intention,
et j’ai tout mis dans un logiciel
pour que les gestes se transforment
en petites cases,
dont je pouvais cocher
la présence ou l’absence.
J’espérais ainsi extraire
des tendances statistiques
me permettant d’expliquer ceci
grâce à une démarche standardisée,
reproductible,
mais surtout irréfutable.
Ça n’a pas marché.
Les gestes qui naissent
d’émotions puissantes
ne peuvent pas être
traduits de manière binaire
en cochant des cases dans un logiciel.
Mais que faire pour comprendre un geste
qui paraît parfaitement
incompréhensible au premier abord ?
En revenant à la source de tout.
A notre nature profonde.
Les humains qui ont
commis toutes les atrocités
et toutes les merveilles du monde
ont un fabuleux point commun avec nous.
Ce sont des Sapiens.
Ils sont si semblables à nous-mêmes
qu’en théorie rien de ce qu’ils ont
inventé n’est inatteignable
pour notre cerveau actuel qui a
si peu changé depuis le Paléolithique.
Pour résoudre ce cas, il faut donc faire
appel à un champ d'investigation commun
entre l'archéologue et le romancier.
L'imagination.
Certains mystères de l’archéologie
ne peuvent être résolus
que grâce à des qualités
que l’on attribue plus souvent, à tort,
à l’écrivain qu’au scientifique,
c’est-à-dire l’émotion, la sensation,
voire la rêverie.
Face à ce corps hybride,
j’ai rêvé de créatures mythiques,
de satyres millénaires,
de sacrifices sanglants
et j’ai ouvert le champ des possibles
pour proposer un lot d’interprétations
non pas irréfutables mais très plausibles.
Alors, bien sûr, l’archéologue
qui s’en remet à son imagination
pour interpréter un vestige
ne peut pas être certain
de ne pas déformer la réalité.
Et trahir la parole des ancêtres
de temps en temps, malheureusement,
ça fait partie des risques quotidiens
du métier de l’archéologue.
Mais doit-on pour autant
se retenir de partager avec vous
une interprétation archéologique
sous prétexte qu’elle est réfutable ?
Absolument pas.
Sinon nous ne partagerions
aucune interprétation archéologique
et nous passerions alors à côté
du but même de notre métier
qui est de faire exister dans vos mémoires
tous ces gens ordinaires dont les livres
d’histoire ont effacé les traces,
trop éblouis qu’ils étaient
par les épopées des rois
et des seigneurs de guerre.
Bien sûr, au-delà de toutes
ces petites histoires individuelles,
qui sont pour moi les plus touchantes,
il reste la grande histoire
de l’humanité à écrire.
Mais c’est justement en agglutinant
les témoignages de ces vies modestes,
que l’archéologue peut espérer passer
de la compréhension des événements
à la compréhension
des phénomènes sociétaux.
Il peut alors vous fournir
un récit puissant sur le passé
qui vous permettra de regarder
vos ancêtres droit dans les yeux.
Au milieu de toutes les biographies
qu’il aura réussi à écrire,
l’archéologue racontera toujours
quelques histoires à dormir debout.
Mais il pourra se consoler en se disant
que malgré ses errances interprétatives,
il aura peut-être éveillé les consciences
de ses concitoyens à des sujets importants
qui résonnent très fortement
dans notre présent.
La condition des femmes,
la condition des personnes
en situation de handicap,
la diversité culturelle et identitaire,
notre rapport à la nature
qui nous environne.
Tous ces bénéfices ne sont-ils pas
plus grands que la petite gêne
que l’archéologue peut recevoir
lorsqu’il s’aperçoit qu’il s’est trompé,
pour une fois ?
Personnellement, je le crois,
sinon je prendrais
ma retraite d’archéologue-écrivain.
Je suis convaincue que rendre leur voix
à nos ancêtres devenus muets par l’oubli
peut permettre à mes contemporains
de se réapproprier le passé
qui leur revient de droit
et qui leur sert de socle.
Je crois que les voix provenant
d’autres dimensions que les nôtres
nous aident à mieux vivre notre humanité
dans notre dimension, ici et maintenant.
C’est pour cette raison
que je continue d’écrire
et j’espère que vous continuerez de lire.
De lire des romans,
des documents historiques,
des essais anthropologiques
pour que nous puissions,
à travers des récits quotidiens
ou extraordinaires,
communier tous ensemble
autour de notre humanité commune.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)